starting today local businesses affected
by the coronavirus shutdowns
can start applying for a new round of
grants it's much
needed help it's a lifeline for a lot of
those small business owners here in the
valley
hector mejia live this morning to
explain how those business owners can
apply
hector good morning
hey there john good morning and these
grants are for small businesses
operating in unincorporated clark county
the only way to apply
is online we're talking about clark
county small business stabilization
program
information is on your screen now the
grants will award up to ten thousand
dollars in free money depending on the
size of the business
a county business license is required
and shops must have
twenty or fewer workers the assistants
can pay for things like
rent utilities inventory payrolls and
more
earlier this summer more than 500 small
businesses received
just about two million dollars in grants
which are funded through the cares act
passed by congress back in march since
then we've talked to
dozens of small businesses that have
been hurting
there's a lot of sleepless nights going
on right now as a business owner a small
business owner especially community
based business owner
so to get that lifeline is uh i'm just
so grateful and humbled that that was
we were able to do that
businesses that got money during the
first round of grants are encouraged to
apply again
applications are due two weeks from
today september 29th
we have information on our website eight
newsnow dot com and those applications
will take
between two and three weeks to get
processed reporting live this morning
hector mejia
8 news now